you know how sharks have you pet this
way it really hurts and it could poke
you and said never penetrate and neither
of ID says the fact
hi I'm Linea my name is UI and my name
is Alton today we're going to be working
with a concept artist to build my dream
dragon my name is Adam and I'm the
concept artist that we're working with
the kids to design their dream dragons
for DreamWorks how to train your dragon
the hidden world the kids know that
they'll be getting a piece of concept
art from me but what they don't know is
that I'll be partnering up with my
friends Amon and Kim to transform the
artwork into fully rendered and 3d
printed painted 3d models the movie
comes out February 22nd so we better get
started
cracking all right let's do it Harlan
eeeh
hi how are you doing good good tell me
about your dragon she is six feet tall
it's like owlish okay
owl size yeah his head makes up three
foot uh-huh
his body makes up six foot and his tail
makes up one foot she's not really an
ordinary dragon Neptune breeds hot pink
cotton candy when you said it's owl
featured talent doesn't touch the
feathers are like Stardust and great
what do you think the hardest parts
gonna be your wings cuz I told him that
they move like this basically what he
does is he breathes fire uh-huh to tell
you jokes it is fire jokes uh-huh I like
it so how did the brainstorm go with
Adam it went awesome yeah you write down
everything I told him what does her face
look like well she has beautiful green
eyes
and she has very long eyelashes that
curl up great no work on these drawings
and then we'll come back and have a
dream dragon for you all right so good
yeah so are you excited to see her
dragon yes I'm very excited I'm pretty
sure that it'll be a good dragon because
he seems like a good artist
my overall plan is first of all the
study the original drawings by Nikko
Marlay and see if I can emulate some of
what he has done to start with a rough
sketch you'd take all the information
that was given to you and you just start
playing around and seeing how you can
push the the design choices and
ultimately focus on the story of their
dragons I think for Elton's dragon my
favorite piece is to play with involved
the fact that it isn't a standard sort
of large sized dragon it's meant to sort
of perch on your arm and then the long
tail with the splayed feathers it's
oddly practical I think it would help a
creature with small wings actually fly
in a straight line
I think Linnea has described herself a
little bit in this one I think she
fashions herself as being somewhat
quirky a little offbeat and the desire
for individuality and sort of the fact
that she wants to praise that I really
appreciate in líneas design Eli's
proportions were tough because a
one-foot tail doesn't give you a lot to
work with his head is half the size of
his body so I had to massage that a
little bit to try and make the balance
of shapes work a little bit more
effectively the humour involved allows
me to play with caricature in a way that
is very silly and fun and I really enjoy
silly if I can make myself laugh and the
drawing is successful so now that we're
done with the drawings we're gonna ship
these off to the modelers and they will
take it from there to create the sculpt
this was a really exciting project for
us but usually we have about a month or
so to put together a character of this
scale this time we had two weeks to put
together three dragons at 15 inch size
we loved Adams character designs but we
had to make some changes for 3d print
specifically when it came to engineering
a product that looks good from all
angles we're using 3d printers that have
a max build volume of between 6 to 7
inches and these dragons were going to
be 15 inches tall and wide I'm super
excited to see how the kids will react
to seeing the scale of the finished
products these prints are big
I'm definitely impressed with Amon
scopes and Adams concept art is a good
starting point for me to get into full
creative mode I definitely have my work
cut out for me so I better get to work
for Eli I like that he's a jokester and
he breathes fire when he's angry so I
think his teeth could be a little
orangie or you know some sort of
suggestion at that fire comes out of
there to move on to Elton's I'd like to
bring in a midnight blue to give him
sort of that deep space feeling bring in
some glitter it'll give a nice sparkle
and depth to him Lynnae is dragon
breathes pink cotton candy so I'm gonna
do like a pink fluffy color on the wings
and on her chest and I am definitely
working towards the reactions of the
kids how's it going you like hi how's it
going man ah it's good all right well
it's been a little bit since uh you
described your dragon to me yeah but I
have your finished dragon you ready to
see it yeah yeah all right
oh that's amazing
all the people wolf what do you think
man
it's awesome sauce yes yeah a whole
sauce of Awesome yes why it looks so
cool it does a little one foot tail his
head is basically half his body so you
got that right yeah you like her color
yes and her green eyes always a long
eyelashes well this is for you buddy
sweet yay
thank you now if you just want to wait
right here for a second let's go get
something real quick
she's
[Music]
um
what actual dragon
you think she's beautiful this is epic
it is awesome sauce it has a joke it
happens o'clock across the road he
glossed this is just what I imagined her
looking good
you took my dragon and made it 3d I
didn't do it everyone here thank you
okay how'd you make less 3d printed it
you get an awesome job how'd you like it
great work guys
I hadn't seen the final until today so
just seeing how it all came together I
got to react to it for the first time as
well so it was their little words to
some drawing that I did then two fully
rendered 3d models yeah and then you're
like flourishes and touches just made it
all the better you ready to go guys yeah
front flip over teleportation effortless
[Music]